bonjour et bienvenue sur france 24 sur
radio france internationale nous sommes
à l'union africaine à addis abeba est
notre invité le ministre des affaires
étrangères du maroc nasser bourita avec
moi pour cette interview florence
maurice de rfi
monsieur brut a le premier ministre
palestinien mohammed shtayyeh a déclaré
à la tribune a exhorté l'union africaine
a retiré le statut d'observateur à
israël on aimerait bien comprendre
exactement la position du maroc parce
qu'elle n'est pas très claire est ce que
vous êtes en faveur de ce statut
d'observateur est ce que vous comprenez
les critiques du premier ministre
palestinien à l'égard des pays notamment
arabes qui semble favorable à ce statut
d'observateur moussa faki était dans son
dans son mandat et je ne parle pas du
fond moi je parle d'abord de la
procédure
trois ou quatre pays ont annoncé chez
eux
qu'ils allaient combattre cette décision
ils sont venus à partir de cette
surenchère nationale pour imposer leur
position ici à l'union avril je pense là
aussi qu'il faut comprendre que l'une
africain a changé qui n'est plus la
chasse gardée d'un pays aux deux qui
peuvent dire non on va bloquer et que
l'organisation va les suivre
l'afrique a changé de nom africain n'a
changé et les débats non membres et il
se trouve aujourd'hui que 44 pays
africains ont des relations avec israël
44 je pensais et margaret thatcher qui
avait dit un jour sur le nu c'est le
miroir qui reflète une réalité si cette
réalité ne plaît pas quatre pays
il faut la changer d'abord sur le
terrain il y a un parmi les pays qui qui
sont les promoteurs de ce débat
qu'ils ont reçues il y a une semaine
l'ambassadeur d'israël et qui ont une
ambassade avec un drapeau d'israël qui
flottent je parle de l'afrique du sud
comment on peut accepter une réalité
chez soi et venir imposer le contraire
au niveau de l'union a filé recrutent je
pense que c'est une c'est un réflexe que
l'union africaine est une chasse gardée
qu'on peut faire à l'union africaine ce
qu'on veut ce n'est plus le cas si vous
êtes favorable à ce statut d'observateur
on peut le dire c'est clairement ce que
l'on est favorable à la mise en oeuvre
des textes cette organisation certains
considèrent que si le maroc tient ce
discours c'est parce que votre pays au
fonds privilégie ces accords commerciaux
et de défense avec israël aujourd'hui
sur la cause palestinienne
c'est faux l'apport du maroc depuis feu
sa majesté un médecin feu sa majesté
même si aujourd'hui avec sa majesté
noirs métis sont bien connues le maroc
est engagé aux côtés du peuple
palestinien nous tous on est pour une
solution à deux états lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on est pour une solution à deux
états c'est qu'on doit reconnaître deux
états qui doivent vivre côte à côte dans
la paix et dans la quiétude c'est ça la
position du maroc et là là là
le rétablissement des relations avec
israël ne changera aucunement la
position du maroc sur la question
palestinienne est ce que votre
rapprochement avec israël les accords de
coopération que vous avez ne vous met
pas un peu en difficulté sur cette
question qui divise aujourd'hui un
éclair par rapport à ses positions
lorsqu on instrumentalise pas les causes
des autres ça ne pose pas de
contradiction et le maroc souhaite
également que l'évolution de sa relation
avec
avec israël puisse permettre la
réalisation des droits du peuple
palestinien avoir un état indépendant
l'algérie
vous accuse de coopérer militairement
avec israël pour l'intimider qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ces accusations
bon ça fait moi ça fait longtemps que
j'ai arrêté de suivre ce que dit
l'algérie ou la diplomatie algérienne
parce que je vois qu'il ya beaucoup de
contradictions beaucoup de choses si ma
mémoire est bonne lorsque l'algérie a
décidé de rompre les relations
il y avait six ou sept points 5 passes
et pas seulement cette question
l'algérie a évoqué le sahara l'algérie a
évoqué n'a guère de 63 la gérer
l'algérie avec a évoqué beaucoup de
choses je pense que c'était
délirant qui avait dit qu'on c'est
excessif c'est lorsque c'est excessif
c'est devient insignifiant et je pense
que lorsqu'on est dans l'excès on a plus
d'impact
l'algérie a pris des positions
unilatérales
c'est son droit la démarche de sa
majesté le roi a été de ne pas
aller vers l' escalade de ne pas même
pas réagir à ces décisions unilatérales
et ça sera toujours votre position donc
l'algérie dans l'excellent excès ce qui
est excessif est insignifiant mais les
positions du maroc sont claires est ce
que pour vous les hypothèses d'une
confrontation militaire directe entre
vos deux pays est envisageable
aujourd'hui exclue le maroc n'est pas
dans l'escalier le maroc ne suit pas
l'avenir et le maroc pense que la
confiance jamais la géographie mais le
maroc comme je les dis
la démarche de sa majesté le roi
ne pas aller dans la l'escalette et de
se concentrer sur ce qui nous unit parce
qu'ils surent nous disent unis alors au
sahara le cessez-le-feu qui était en
vigueur plus ou moins depuis 1991 a été
rompu il ya eu des affrontements
militaires est ce que on est dans une
situation de guerre de quasi guerre ou
est-ce que ça reste des petites
escarmouches à vos yeux militairement le
maroc et dans son territoire et le maroc
est dans sa légitime défense le maroc
n'a jamais cherché
la confrontation de maroc et pour
une solution dans le cadre des nations
unies de ce problème dans le cadre de
l'autonomie sous souveraineté marocaine
et ceux qui auraient rejeté les
résolutions du conseil de sécurité n'est
pas le maroc qui a sorti un communiqué
en octobre pour dire je rejette la
résolution adoptée par le conseil de
sécurité
c'est ce pays-là qui a officiellement
rejeté la volonté de la communauté
internationale à propos est-ce que
l'initiative de l'envoyé spécial des
nations unies
un avenir où est-ce que c'est mission
impossible on a le sentiment que la
situation est bloquée l'algérie reste
sur la même position à savoir des
négociations directes entre vous et le
polisario ce que vous refusez est ce
qu'on n'est pas dans une impasse il faut
pas mettre l'algérie le maroc sur un
pied d'égalité le banquier temps libre
le maroc est aligné sur la résolution du
conseil de sécurité
l'algérie ne veut pas cette résolution
d' oncle pour le maroc et les à l'aise
l'envoyé personnel à un mandat un cadre
d'action lui même dit qu'il travaille
pour les table ronde si l'algérie ne
veut pas si son problème mais ce que
vous pensez que ça va se débloquer
moi je pense que le en tout cas pour le
royaume du maroc il ya une volonté pour
trouver une solution dans le cadre de
l'initiative d'autonomie marocaine et
rien que l'initiative d'autonomie
marocaine
le cadre c'est un cadre des tables
rondes avec la participation de la
véritable parti à ce différend régional
dans ce couloir demandez à n'importe
quel diplomate le problème du sahara il
est entre qui et qui lorsqu'on est un
acteur de ce problème l avantage de
cette escalade algérienne ce que
l'algérie aujourd'hui à démontrer qu'il
est la véritable parti à ce problème
c'est dans la salle il n'y a que
l'algérie qui prend la parole sur ce
dossier je veux en venir au dossier
libyen
rapidement la communauté internationale
a pesé de tout son poids pour que des
élections se tiennent absolument le 24
décembre n'importe qui un minimum
informé savait que les conditions
n'étaient pas réunies que ça n'allait
pas arriver est ce que vous pensez que
la communauté internationale a eu tort
de pousser absolument à ces élections
dont on savait bien qu'elle n'allait pas
avoir lieu ce sont les libyens eux mêmes
qui ont choisi lors du dialogue de
genève le 24 décembre ils ont mis les
institutions et les processus pour ça
tout le monde savait que ça n'allait pas
être facile
mais aujourd'hui au moins on a deux ou
trois avantages par rapport à la
situation antérieure
il y a un an et demi
tripoli était bombardée et on pensait
que la situation la solution ne pouvait
être que militaire en libye
aujourd'hui on voit que les gens sont en
train de débattre de la base
constitutionnelle de la loi électorale
de la compagnie comment la le cadre de
la con électorale donc déjà tout le
monde à travers ce processus des
élections s'est inscrit dans la démarche
politique et tout le monde s'est départi
de la démarche militaire deuxième acquis
les obstacles à la tenue des élections
étaient identifiés et aujourd'hui il
faut travailler pour dépasser à ces
obstacles et c'est ça le travail que le
maroc essaie de faire avec les
différents protagonistes libyens
3 les institutions ont montré leur
utilité
le parlement le conseil d'état ont saisi
dans ciel et le gouvernant le maroc est
contre le fait de créer un vide en libye
en dénigrant les institutions quand les
aime qu'on les aime pas mais au moins
aujourd'hui ces institutions permettent
à l'état libyen devant de continuer à
fonctionner a travaillé pour la
préparation des élections en travaillant
sur celles qui ont été identifiées à
travers le processus qui n'a pas été
conclue le 24 décembre
au delà de la question du report des
élections on voit bien que les questions
que ça soulève et dont vous parlez
exacerbe dans le pays un certain nombre
de tensions est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir encore que la
perspective d'une dune élection s'est
éloigné fortement pour longtemps je
pense qu'il y avait qu il y aussi une
une perception or centric qui fait de
l'élection le
la panacée pour résoudre dans le
contexte libyen est un est un contexte
particulier l'objectif c'est de régler
la question de la légitimité mais sans
perdre la stabilité de la libye
c'est pour cela qu'il faut cet équilibre
comment avancer vers les élections mais
sans créer le chaos et la démarche du
maroc a été toujours une démarche
réaliste et pragmatique qui
responsabilise d'abord les acteurs
libyens on peut avoir tout les organiser
toutes les conférences internationales
en europe et ailleurs et établir des
recettes mais ce que ces recettes sont
adaptées au contexte libyen c'est ça le
véritable problème aujourd'hui les
élections reste un objectif je pense aux
lib et le maroc y croit mais pas une fin
en soi on a une fin en soi parce que le
plus important c'est que ce pays
retrouve sa stabilité retrouve son rôle
parce que pour le maroc comme l'a dit sa
majesté le roi la libye on n'est pas
voisins mais la libé très proche parce
que sa stabilité ne touche son
instabilité nous touchent et les liens
entre les deux pays sont très importants
ils sont présents siens le seul ministre
merci merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
sur nos deux antennes rfi et france 24
merci
[Musique]